welcome back to cbs mornings this year's
first direct test of abortion as an
election issue suggests that voters will
go to the polls to have their say kansas
is the first state to have abortion
rights on the ballot since the supreme
court overturned the roe v wade decision
in june there's been a huge increase in
early voting for today's primary and
caitlyn huey burns is in olathe a suburb
in kansas city with more good morning
good morning jerica well voters here in
kansas are voting on an amendment to the
state's constitution that would remove
protections for abortion and if it
passes the republican-led state
legislature could enact further
restrictions or a near total ban on the
procedure and voters here in kansas have
been telling us that this feels even
bigger than a presidential level
campaign
hi how are you
knocking on doors and rallying voters in
90 degree heat
activists on both sides of one of the
most divisive issues in the country are
making sure voters know that access to
abortion is literally on the ballot
walking down the streets in these
suburban neighborhoods it's easy to find
very different points of view ideally of
course i think we would all love a total
ban we do live in a realistic world so
even if we could get restrictions we
would be
very thankful and happy for that for
lori muscata the issue is personal when
i was 15 years old
i accepted ride home from work from a
co-worker and
he took me down to the river and left me
there
i screamed no
and i wasn't heard then he didn't listen
to me
but i'm going to vote no and people are
going to listen i am a christian woman
but i had that choice back then and i
want every woman to have that choice
voting no will keep abortion rights in
place voting yes will overturn them and
allow the state legislature which is
controlled by republicans to act do you
think it would empower the state
legislature to add restrictions well
obviously the legislature can write new
laws
but the trick is getting everyone on the
same page
so it's going to be an uphill battle but
as a lawmaker do you want to see a ban
well my personal opinion
uh i think we need more restrictions
it's creating a manufactured health care
crisis and now it's like hundreds of
phone calls rebecca tong is the
co-executive director of a wichita
abortion clinic which has seen an influx
in calls from patients states away
several neighboring states have banned
abortion already
they're coming here to kansas what does
that mean for them it means that their
state has left them behind that they
are going to be forced to carry their
pregnancy further than they wanted
if the measure passes tonight abortions
will still be legal here in kansas but
only until the state legislature goes to
act and they come back into session in
january vlad
all right caitlin thank you very much